this morning
an ROV or remote operated vehicle from
The Vessel Horizon Arctic discovered the
tail cone of the Titan submersible
approximately 1600 feet
from the bow of the Titanic on the sea
floor
the ROV subsequently
found additional debris
in consultation with experts from within
the unified command the debris is
consistent with the catastrophic loss
of the pressure chamber
upon this determination we immediately
notified the families
on behalf of the United States Coast
Guard and the entire unified command
I offer my deepest condolences to the
families
I Can Only Imagine
what this has been like for them
and I hope that this discovery
provides
some soulless during this difficult time
additionally we've been in close contact
with the British and French consul
General to ensure that they are fully
apprised and that their concerns are
being addressed
the outpouring of support in this highly
complex search operation has been robust
and immensely appreciated
we are grateful for the rapid
mobilization of experts on the undersea
search and rescue and we thank all of
the agencies and personnel
for their role in the response
we're also incredibly grateful for the
full spectrum of international
assistance that's been provided
the rovs will remain on scene and
continue to gather information
again
our most heartfelt condolences
go out to the loved ones of the crew